mesdames et messieurs bonjour j'aurais
aimé vous dire bonjour dans une salle
pleine mais comme vous pouvez le
constater en ce moment nous sommes dans
une période un peu difficile de la foire
qu'on s'adapte on trouve des moyens des
solutions finding wise c'est une belle
présentation qu'on va vous faire
aujourd'hui avec mes collègues de ce
matin à lille ça alors je fais ça pour
soi disant lire mais je ne vois pas
comme vous avez pu constater je suis en
situation de handicap j'ai un petit
problème visuel j'ai envie de dire ça
saute aux yeux
je vais pas vous m'attarder sur mon
parcours personnel ou professionnel
si je suis venu aujourd'hui c'est
surtout pour vous raconter comment je me
suis adapté
comment j'ai pu trouver un moyen comment
j'ai pu entre guillemets survivre à ce
qui m'arrive c'est à dire mon handicap
et pour vous raconter tout ça on va
parcourir un petit plan qui s'affiche à
l'écran donc dans un premier temps vous
présenter pourquoi je pense qu'on trouve
des solutions avant de 1.5 chercher des
moyens vous raconter comment moi j'ai pu
me faire grâce à un socle prix mondial
qui consiste en la famille et l'amour et
l'amour des lettres et du savoir dans un
troisième temps nous allons voir comment
j'ai pu évoluer d'une forme de curiosité
au développement du sens critique
ensuite comprendre grâce aux nouvelles
technologies comment est ce que j'ai pu
vraiment de développer une plasticité
cérébrale
1 parce que ça existe vraiment
aujourd'hui il ya des études qui
commence à démontrer que les personnes
malvoyantes ou qu'ils perdent la vue du
père d'un sens non pas un sixième sens
au contraire mais à une mutation de
leurs capacités cérébrales ce qui vous
rend forcément parfois opportuniste
comme vous êtes en situation de handicap
ou créer du lien social
mais ça va développer chez vous en tout
cas chez moi une certaine audace
on veut dire j'ai pas froid aux yeux et
puis ben forcément là où vous pensez que
je n'ai aucune actualité
et que sais je ne vois pas c'est là où
je vais vous répondre que j'ai au
contraire une vision interne comme si un
certain auteur jacques lui serrant qui
étaient résistants les aveugles la
vision interne c'est la vision du
bonheur
et puis on parle de bonheur on parle
d'émotion on parle d'intelligence
émotionnelle on parle de rapports aux
autres et c'est là où j'ai vraiment
trouvé le plus d'épanouissement et j'ai
trouvé les moyens justement de cette
ambition et en conclusion je vous
expliquerai pourquoi pour moi je pense
que les moyens on ne peut pas les
trouver sans réfléchir et sans se
projeter dans une solution commençons
pour introduire notre sujet par une
slide avec des personnalités qui me sont
chers j'allais dire cher à mes yeux
nelson mandela en résistant 27 ans
d'incarcération a pu n'ont pas développé
le moyen de résister à sa prison mais
trouver une solution pour son pays en
devenant un symbole de liberté alors que
lui voulait juste résister à
l'incarcération
au fil de ses 27 années il est devenu un
symbole de liberté dont elle a trouvé
une solution pour sortir de la crise
politique de la guerre civile qui allait
naître dans son pays moyens que helen
keller femme sourde et aveugle de
naissance a pu trouver pour apprendre le
braille apprendre le sens apprendre les
mots devenir une grande hauteur une des
plus grandes du siècle dernier
sa consoeur au tout aussi exceptionnel
béatrice vidéo qui avait subi un
accident de la vie dramatique en
trouvant des moyens de reprendre une vie
normale est devenue une des plus grande
combattante en escrime des plus grande
championne paralympique de sa discipline
alors qu'elle n'a pas de poignées en a
pas deux membres supérieurs et la gagner
face à des adversaires qui ont des
poignets des membres supérieurs qui
fonctionne et enfin un ami cher à mes
yeux aussi
mais qu'ils agiraient bien est ce qui
après un accident de ski à l'âge de 18
ans se retrouve dans une situation
compliquée de rééducation est recherché
en serait du quai à s'émanciper alors
revivre entre guillemets est devenu un
des plus grands champions paralympiques
de la discipline en france de tennis je
vous parlais tout à l'heure de deux
sortes d'ingrédients pour trouver des
moyens pour ce qui m'a permis de
résister de faire de cette fameuse
faiblesse que vous voyez là une force
tout d'abord il ya le socle familial ses
prix mondial de l'amour et du savoir mon
père était-il d'être il est né en 1948
en algérie sous la halle à décoloniser
le régime de la décolonisation
ils ne savaient pas lire ni écrire une
fois il m'a raconté une anecdote il m'a
dit tu quand il est arrivé en france à
69 il a commencé par faire de la
livraison avec un camion et comme ils ne
savaient pas lire une fois il s'était
trompé il a dû faire un détour de cette
heure il n'a pas eu ça paye ma mère n'a
pas pu manger mon frère et ma soeur
aînée n'ont pas eu d'argent sale a
traumatisé et il a fait de cette
recherche de culture de l'apprentissage
la formation le fer de lance de notre
éducation avec mes frères et soeurs et
moi ma mère elle était une jeune fleur
une noire a comme on dit algéroise qui
était assez éduqués et les deux ont
formé un couple complémentaire puisque
ma mère elle m'a donné beaucoup d'amour
comme en droit d'attendre d'une lumière
quand on a la chance d'en avoir une main
surtout donné l'amour des autres aller
vers les autres et c'était primordial
parce qu'à ce moment là quand j'étais
gamin je savais pas que j'allais perdre
la vue rajoutez à ça de la pauvreté et
du handicap et vous obtenez un
environnement qui vous rend résilient
donc l'environnement doit vous rendre
résidents c'est quelque chose qui fait
que vous êtes prêt destinées d'une
certaine manière à trouver des moyens de
manière naturelle pour évoluer ou vous
adapter mais est ce que le socle de
valeurs le cercle familial suffit quand
on se retrouve justement dans cette
situation de handicap
comment est ce qu'on fait quand on ne
sait pas lire quand on ne peut pas dire
pas forcément développe soit le toucher
pour apprendre le braille
soit on fait appel aux nouvelles
technologies et les nouvelles
technologies en ce qui me concerne il a
plusieurs
les nouvelles technologies c'est
forcément l'utilisation d'un ordinateur
d'un pc et pour utiliser un pc il faut
utiliser un clavier ce qui a été
vraiment fondamental dans mon évolution
intellectuelle en tant que mal voyants
pour arriver à travailler à faire le
parcours que j'ai à voir le parcours que
j'ai vu c'était maîtriser le clavier est
gelée après partir donc je connais la
moindre des touches que ce soit dû à
jusqu'au contrôle à l'entrée du clavier
ce qui m'a permis aussi
d'avoir une grande maîtrise de l'outil
bureautique et de l'informatique
maintenant il ya aussi ce qu'il appelle
moi la vision interne qui s'est
développée grâce à ce logiciel c'est une
synthèse vocale qui est aussi disponible
sur mon smartphone et il faut savoir que
l'être humain comme vous lisez que ce
soit en diagonale ou en lecture rapide
vous lisez en moyenne entre 150 à 200 mo
minutes pour ma part je suis à 400
minutes ce qui fait que ça m'a au fil
des années développé une capacité
d'acquisition des connaissances et de
restitution du discours de manière assez
phénoménal parce que ça a développé la
mémoire du travail on en reparlera tout
à l'heure mais pour vous illustrer ce
que je raconte on fait une petite
démonstration un de nos chers élèves de
ligne ça va lire un petit texte que
j'avais préparé on va le chronomètre et
trois deux un top always looking
difficile de regarder au loin quand vous
se trouve être quasi non voyants mais
voilà bien une devise empreinte de
dérision qui caractérise bien l'adn de
nasser organique
l'humour polyvalence et résilience
faisant de son parcours et son profil un
exemple vivant de ce que pourrait être
un éclectisme atypique top on a eu une
très jolie voix une juridiction
maintenant on va faire dire mon ami la
synthèse vocale attention 3 2 un top
l'écart entre les deux est en moyenne de
7 à 8 secondes en ayant cette capacité à
intégrer les informations de manière
très très rapide j'ai augmenté ma
capacité de mémorisation la capacité de
restitution et forcément j'ai activé
certaines zones du cerveau le cortex
visuel primaire et la zone du cerveau
qui permet à notre vision d'exister donc
il ya une différence entre voir et
percevoir la vision est inversée au sein
de l'oeil et grâce à la racine et vous
pourrez percevoir tout ce que vous voyez
autour de vous en ce qui me concerne on
pourrait croire que comme le dit lui le
commun le sixième sens prend le relais
que j'entende mieux je touche me c'est
totalement faux ce sont des idées reçues
sont répandues depuis très longtemps
dans l'imaginaire collectif mais c'est
totalement faux en ce qui me concerne
je peux vous dire que ce qui a été le
plus développé dans mon esprit c'est la
mémoire il ya des recherches notamment
l'université de tel aviv et certains
laboratoires parisiens en termes de
plasticité du cerveau qui ont permis de
compenser l'utilisation de technologies
adaptées de basse vision
pour activer des zones du cortex visuel
primaires et on s'est rendu compte quand
même en utilisant des logiciels ou en
utilisant la mémoire du travail
les synthèses vocales la capacité
d'analyser le langage c activée chez des
sujets aveugles ou malvoyants certaines
zones du cerveau qui correspondent à une
vision donc en effet le cortex études
primaires continuent à fonctionner mais
de manière différente
voilà une dimension après le socle après
la technologie il ya aussi le rapport
aux autres le rapport à l'humain et
surtout l'analyse si la légère le le
facteur chance mais la chance qui
n'existe pas en effet s'il ya ce qu'on
appelle l'opportunisme être aller coûte
être attentif sur ce qui vous entoure
moi mon père m'a toujours dit dans son
éducation qui m'a donné déjà le premier
point le plus important c'est d'être
capable de tenir ses promesses
napoléon disait que le meilleur moyen de
ne pas honorer vous n'allez pas tenir
une promesse c'est tout simplement de ne
pas en donner parce que juste mon père
m'a dit au contraire un homme entre
guillemets avec un grand h ou une femme
avec un grand f
s'il veut être jean il doit être en
capacité de tenir ses promesses mais
est-ce que ça suffit vraiment ma mère
elle m'a apporté ce côté un peu sociable
elle m'a dit d'aller vers les autres et
puis le handicap vous oblige à
développer des capacités que vous
puissiez demander votre chemin que vous
puissiez demander à quelqu'un de vous
décrire un tableau ou au restaurant
savoir comment des ça développe chez
vous une capacité rhétorique finalement
en étant au contact des autres vous
trouvé juste le moyen de développer un
sens rhétorique et je parlerai aussi est
d'une mètres d'une matière non qui m'a
vraiment plu c'était à la fac
c'était la logique la logique c'est une
matière philosophie qui vous intrigue
mais apprend à voir les textes avec les
connecteurs logique avec les adductions
les déductions les enchaînements avec
les arguments d'autorité etc et vous
commencez à analyser le monde avec une
certaine logique et finalement qu'est-ce
que la logique si ce n'est le meilleur
moyen pour une personne aveugle ou en
situation de handicap de trouver sa voie
par exemple je suis très entre
guillemets amusé de voir les
les gens sur le quai du tgv demandez aux
contrôleurs alors qu'ils sont la voiture
3 ou est-ce que se situe la voiture 8
mais c'est logique voiture 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
c'est très logique mais les gens en
général quand on voit de ses yeux on est
poli on fait plus attention au sens
critique et à la logique on a plus de
discernement en fait il ya une chose que
j'ai apprise et en philosophie c'était
le kaïros le kaïros l'équivalent du
kronos mais lui est dédié à
l'appréhension du temps dans un temps de
donner pour à savoir à peu près là quel
moment on peut faire une action si c'est
trop tôt c'est trop tard c'est trop tard
c'est trop tard aussi donc c'est savoir
à quel moment être capable d'attraper
une notion d'attraper ce moment dans
votre vie pour soi pour un stage pour un
emploi pour une rencontre amoureuse est
toujours si vous avez l'impression que
dans l'air il ya un air de flottement de
chance et un flottement de paramètres
qui font que et bien ça c'est le kairos
et pour savoir le détecter il faut être
à l'écouté il faut être à l'affût et le
handicap m'a rendu un peu à l'affût avec
mes sens sans soutif aider mon sens de
l'esprit bien sûr alors tout ça c'est
bien beau mais on est dans la théorie
est aussi la pratique
finalement je me suis rendu compte au
fil de ses 18 ans grâce aussi à une
autre discipline non pas les études
n'ont pas le monde du professionnel mais
les arts martiaux japonais en
particulier la boxe anglaise
nous sommes rendu compte que non
seulement la vue n'était pas un obstacle
dans la pratique de ce sport là avec en
plus j'étais d'une précision diabolique
par exemple je sais que le pied est ici
l'ordinateur est ici la caméra c est ici
dans cet axe je pense et la caméra
grandes banques si je me souviens bien
elle est là bas l'entrée il ya une
entrée ici et je peux même être en
capacité de vous dessinez le plan de
l'issat pour mettre un peu de pratique
dans tout ça d'accord juste avant je
vais vous parler aussi du mythe du
superhéros passe comme vous voulez voir
sur la photo je veux bien jared eu droit
à un ancien champion du monde de boxe
anglaise lors d'un gala qui a été
organisé à marseille est en fait au fil
des années j'ai non seulement appris à
mémoriser la taille mais aussi la
morphologie des corps et a riposté en
fonction des goûts que je recevais grâce
à l'angle
avec lequel j'ai été touché tout ça en
développant cette vision interne cette
activité bon passons à plus de pratique
avec la démonstration par a plus b que
je vais vous dessinez le plan d'accès
avec les différents édifices de ligne ça
pourtant c'est la première fois que je
viens ici alors nous sommes ici à linz a
dans ce qu'on appelle la rotonde la
rotonde qui est un cercle que l'on va
dessiner ici ensuite nous sommes venus
par ici et comme vous pouvez le voir sur
la vidéo qui tourne en même temps c'est
le dernier chemin que nous avons
parcouru avec des courts de tennis ici
qui sont derrière et des résidences ils
sont là bas on se repositionne sur le
chemin et on va tracer un trait ici par
où nous sommes venus et quand nous
sommes venus par ici sur notre gauche il
y avait ce qu'on appelle l'immeuble sadi
carnot et juste derrière un immeuble en
travaux sur la droite quand nous sommes
venus nous avons traversé une grande
place la place de l'humanité avec
l'immeuble des sciences humaines qui est
ici et nous étions venus d'un autre
grand immeuble on appelle jules verne
d'ailleurs il y avait des produit
inflammable et toxique on est bien dans
une école d'ingénieurs et sur la gauche
ici là-bas au loin il y avait ce qu'on
appelle le bâtiment du génie électrique
une fois que nous étions à jules verne
juste avant de rentrer dans cet immeuble
nous avons traversé une longue allée
depuis le tramway qui est ici qui coupe
le campus en perpendiculaire et ici
c'est le sud
ici c'est le nord à l'ouest se trouve le
rhône et la part dieu avec le la biotech
universitaire je pense et de l'autre
côté ici se trouve la biotech de ligne
ça juste avant de rentrer sur ce chemin
sur notre gauche j'ai eu la joie de
découvrir le meuble pasteur merci
l'immeuble pasteur et sur la droite ici
il y avait un autre amphithéâtre
l'amphithéâtre laura bazille et si on
revient au niveau du tramway ont tracé
un nouveau très droit jusqu à mon hôtel
qui étaient ici et en rentrant en ayant
traversé la rue en faisant se lever
cette petite boucle
ici on avait le restaurant universitaire
ici on a vu aussi mercy corps et son
université a ici et on avait votre
résidence sur l'étude de l'insee ici et
en face un l'immeuble mystérieux que
personne n'assume d'écrire et nous
avions pris 7 en or et avec ce petit
passage piéton et nous étions dans mon
hôtel voilà ce que j'appelle une vision
interne c'est la première fois que je
viens
jugeant capacité de retracer dans ma
tête en temps réel le plan de ligne ça
alors est ce que c est ce que ça
correspond les étudiants vous le dire
alors tout ceci c'est bien beau mais il
ya une composante il ya une dimension
qui n'est pas de la logique qui n'est
pas la nouvelle technologie qui n'est
pas la visualisation spatiale qui n'est
pas la vision interne que j'ai pu
développer c'est l'émotion
le fait d'avoir très tôt vécu ce
handicap était devenu pour moi une force
ça a été aussi grâce à l'émotion j'ai
développé une capacité à être une éponge
émotionnel a parfois c'est difficile
quand vous avez des amis qui ont des
problèmes etc
mais parfois ça peut être très utile
pour comprendre le monde qui vous
entoure parce qu'en développant
l'intelligence émotionnelle j'ai pu me
rapprocher des autres alors j'étais pas
du tout prédestiné à devenir un animal
social parce que quand j'avais 17 ans
j'ai commencé à perdre la vue ça m'a
fait tellement peur ça m'a terrorisée
que je suis devenu agoraphobe
j'étais terrorisée par le fait de ne pas
avoir de me cogner de tomber de dire à
quelqu'un et des mois est en fait au fil
des années quand j'ai développé cette
vision interne je me suis rendu compte
que c'était aussi grâce au récepteur
savait qu'on a des récepteurs chimiques
comme la dopamine s'ils retournent etc
et certains se développe par le toucher
par le contact et au fil des années j'ai
carrément développer une personnalité
très exubérante très atypique pour créer
du lien et pour aller sans doute vers
les autres vous connaissez sûrement le
test du bti avec 50 avec ses codes
couleurs aussi dans les tests de
psychologie le jaune correspond à
quelqu'un qui brille comme le soleil qui
est au centre de l'énergie qu'ils
dégagent de la chaleur le rouge
correspond à antrim et un leader un chef
de guerre le vert correspond à une
personne qui aime se mettre au service
des autres et le bleu correspond à
quelques uns des très cartésien de très
fines très carré et raie sharp
moi je pense je suis très jaune très
rouge mais je peux comprendre les verts
et les jaunes si j'avais une chose à
vous dire pour conclure c'est qu'il ya
une différence entre voir et savoir en
ce qui me concerne c'est le savoir qui
m'a permis de devenir l'homme que je
suis alors on dit souvent le savoir est
une arme c'est assez martial comme
vision mais moi je préfère dire que le
savoir est une solution ou un moyen
c'est à vous de déterminer sa en ce qui
me concerne moi ça m'a permis de perdre
la vue de développer des moyens de
comprendre l'environnement de
m'intéresser aux autres de me cultiver
et de développer ce que j'appelle moi un
sens tactique et stratégique
mais dans l'environnement pour ne jamais
dépendre des autres et pour être plus
tôt au service des autres bon à la foire
je trouve le moyen de s'en aller en fait
allez salut
[Applaudissements]